let's talk about how these creepy jerks
are making it difficult for us to have
real conversations
pcmag.com says facebook prods
users who've been exposed to extremist
content to get
help this is where it's get it's getting
weird it's getting real
it's getting weird look at this are you
concerned that someone you know is
becoming an extremist
we care about preventing extremism on
facebook others
in your situation have received
confidential support
the other one says kevin you may have
been exposed to harmful extremist
content recently
violent groups tried to manipulate your
anger and disappointment
you can take action now to protect
yourself and others
all right you can take action everybody
listening you can take action right now
you can smash the like button subscribe
and share this video
that way um people can get a
non-corporate opinion on why this is
creepy and freaky just think about that
that would be a peaceful action though
of course right
yeah very very peaceful pressing that
like button peaceful smashing
yeah that's the big conundrum about
these these networks everyone's like why
don't you get off youtube and it's like
bro we upload a rumble now
we're uploading to rumble now that it's
perfect we've always uploaded
uh have we i don't think irl's on mines
but my personal connects has always been
content has always been yeah we we want
to and we want to make sure we're
leveraging the networks as they exist in
the best of our abilities
so we can keep the network alive think
of it this way
the way i said it before is like do you
retreat from a battlefield
where you're still holding some ground
just because you're like that
battlefield is completely open
it's like not necessarily hold the
ground you can
and so there's a lot of things we can't
talk about and it's getting worse
i'm texting some of these other big
podcast people right now and i'm like yo
what's going on like there's breaking
news we can't talk about it
like i had to i emailed google and i'm
like hey look at this story and they're
like well you know
and i'm all right can't say these things
that's insane
that's how bad and broken this is i've
noticed i think our presence here is
helping
guide the uh the youtube behavior and
like terms a little bit because i
noticed they relax their swearing
uh measurements and they're like you
know what go for it if you want to cuss
feel free
because it's like it's just so
entertaining and if we if we start
cussing it's hilarious
and they know that and they want it to
be hilarious i don't think that's us
sure it is i think so but let's let's
crazy let's talk about this facebook
thing because i want to
look at this they say confidential
support who do you think
at facebook is going to be the person
that will reach out to you when you're
like help help i've seen a post from ben
shapiro oh no
like a psychiatrist that they hire it's
gonna be some woke 20 year olds
yeah or i mean to become honest it's
going to be like some 20 year old
college student from india
yeah no joke i mean outsourcing uh call
center stuff
you're gonna get someone who's you know
probably got a checklist of like
do you feel like you are sad and
depressed no
okay right ben shapiro touch you in any
way
emotional when you said exposed i was
thinking i don't know is this about my
uncle or what is this about you know
what's going on here
these social networks have like huge um
psychology
departments to take care of their admins
because the admins see such vile and
vicious things as they're going through
like making sure like blown off arms are
like horrific stuff
so i wonder if they're using those same
therapists to help now but i don't know
it's
kind of vague i mean but i don't know
what they expect to get out of this
other than creeping people out
but i want to show you this meme from
kerry wedler it says are you concerned
that someone you know is becoming an
extremist we care about preventing
extremism on facebook
others in your situation have received
confidential support and then of course
there's obi-wan kenobi says well of
course i know him he's me
yes we've all been exposed to this
content but define extremists
sure well a biological dissident yeah
when i first saw this i thought for sure
that it was about black lives matter and
antifa but of course
i was not correct of course they're only
talking about the right-wing extremism
that they say is the biggest threat
obviously it should be blm and antifa
but it's not and i feel like this is a
flex
from facebook they're just like oh we're
just gonna show them what we can do
we're watching you we can see what
you're looking at we can see what you're
liking
it's creepy it's absolutely creepy of
course and
the it's kind of like that old
definition of you know what's porn and
the supreme court just said well i know
it when i see it right yeah
it's gonna be one of these things right
we can't operate that way no we can't
like you need to be able to define what
you're talking about
right so so i've been searching my brain
i'm like thinking when was the last time
in history it was awesome when
censorship showed up like
like when did that work out real well
was that the nazi book burnings so the
u.s office of censorship
when did so world war ii loose lip sync
ships
yeah but you know if you're talking
about opsec that might be just a little
bit different from saying i'm going to
talk about a scientific paper which
somebody
approves of right it's a very different
very different beast so what i find
interesting in this is that all remember
i have this i'm cursed with this memory
i can remember all the way back to the
last election
right remember what the there was all
this concern like nazis nazis nazis they
were everywhere right so what are nazis
famous for well i think they're really
famous for
marginalizing and you know shutting
things down
well that's exactly the environment i
feel like i'm living in right now so
of course i've had people call me up and
say chris you don't understand
this is exactly like what it was like
when i was in cuba right when the whole
revolution was going down this is what
it was like
all this older guy you know during the
soviet times right have you have you
heard about the the the parents of
loudoun county no was it was it loudoun
county where that woman said it's
just like the culture revolution chinese
mother the struggle sessions yeah is
that where we are yeah
yeah i mean it's it's shocking that uh
you know there was there was something i
wanted to ask you about
you know you were talking about vaccines
you're talking about efficacy you're
talking about medical treatments what's
your favorite color
blue blue excellent wow ian green green
okay
thanks youtube it's been a blast this is
the kind of content you want on your
platform hahaha
swear word i just learned that
[Laughter]
i learned that that green is in the
middle of the human vision spectrum
so it made me think that maybe we
developed the ability to see green
first and maybe that's because trees and
grass are green
magnesium chlorophyll is green so we
just evolved to see that was the first
color we started to notice dude i
i i i am fairly optimistic i have to
have to be honest i was i was
you know getting pretty pessimistic for
a while and then
um you know michael mouse was a constant
influence on this show is very
optimistic because he's always mocking
and laughing at these people
now i do get some concern when he says
things like you know look how dumb these
people are
how could you possibly be worried about
losing the culture or something that
effect
and i'm like yeah zombies are dumb too
but sometimes the zombies take over
they never stop yeah like and they turn
other people into zombies
so when you see that when you see the
zombie like
head butting into a door and like just
bouncing and they're like look how dumb
it is
and then ten thousand of them are
marching towards you you do get scared
but but i am optimistic for a lot of
reasons mate as i've been saying
recently the night is always darkest
before the dawn
maybe it's bad right now but look at uh
the stuff we've been able to do over it
over at teamcast.com we we've hired a
couple more writers we've got a new
editor coming on we got some we got
new podcasts i am confident that youtube
will be
forced by the market to stop doing what
they're doing
or i i i'll say this i really don't
think it's going to be
republicans they're gonna they're gonna
be like wagging their finger
for the next five years nothing's gonna
happen but uh i i i should say i don't
believe 100
that the market is going to force you to
change but uh look at joe rogan
yeah joe rogan left youtube um for the
most part
took a deal with spotify and he was able
to host
brett weinstein and uh who's other guy
pierre cory yeah
and we can't repeat what they said on
that show but it is a great show and i
highly recommend
everyone everyone watch that show and
the new york times
wrote a pseudo hit piece on joe recently
mentioning the conversations they're
having
now i'm not entirely convinced spotify
is happy
with the conversations they're happening
having but
he's got a deal and they can't just ban
him so it allows
it's like it's like joe got himself
locked into place on a platform that
probably would have banned him if he did
it independently
if joe well joe being joe they probably
would have loved it if he just went to
spotify
but if uh for a channel like this
if we did the same show as joe off of
youtube spotify would probably ban it
they had they had all those employees at
spotify trying to get joe banned
but he's got this deal where he's like
locked into place he's got 11 million
listeners
yeah you know what are they going to do
he's got more listeners than most
nearly all of mainstream media so he's
got power
is that the magic that's come out 11
million listeners i think that's the
last one i heard because like
that's that those he has he has like 10
10 million subscribers on youtube or is
it like 11 million subscribers
i'm wondering how many people still
listen to him on spotify though i don't
anymore
yeah i i haven't no no disrespect like
joe's rad
send him a friend i haven't checked out
i haven't been able to see one of his
shows there was one instance where a
show came up and i like tried pulling up
spotify to figure it out and i just like
i give up you know what i mean yeah
there's a little barrier of entry i used
to just pull the thing on youtube with
no problem
and i would have it like playing to my
left while i'm like reading news and
stuff and i just listen
for a couple hours you know it's harder
when i i have so much respect for brett
weinstein
so i i will go the distance for him and
joe of of course but it really because i
was like you i didn't get spotify i
wouldn't get it i was like f this but
when you see these people i mean he's
friends with some of the most
influential and amazing humans on earth
so i'm going i'm going for that and
spotify knows it their valuation after
they paid
joe whatever it was 100 million or
whatever is up like billions billions of
dollars no and i regretted not buying
any of that stock
because i'm pretty sure like a bunch of
people knew
that it was happening and then like i
didn't even think about it
and then instantly as soon as they
announced it in the press like skyrocket
i'm like
weren't people talking about that behind
the scenes like didn't someone tell me
something about that i gotta pay
attention more to this stuff
i don't think that's insider trading
though i have nothing to do with the
business someone just mentioned hey i
think this thing's gonna happen i'm like
oh i don't care all right dark is before
the dawn though i gotta tell you i know
a lot of people have been
canceled and censored just in the past
two weeks it's getting worse big stuff
right so
so this woman um who works for the flccc
joyce
she writes this this really big article
called the fl ccc oh sorry that's the
frontline covid critical care doctor
that's dr p corey so my first youtube
strike happened when
um i was reviewing his testimony so he
was in front of the senate had like
eight million views i thought this is
safe so i took his
thing i pulled three clips just reacted
to the three clips saying hey you should
listen to what he's saying here it makes
sense
that was my first strike they gave you a
strike that was recently they took down
this guy's senate testimony
they did that too but they gave me the
strike for reviewing the testimony
right i wonder if they're gonna get mad
at us for mentioning the testimony
at all i wouldn't be surprised i don't
think so they might get mad but i don't
it doesn't violate any terms to talk
people
out uh as far as i know to reference it
bro
uh crowder got a strike for mentioning
cdc data
it's it's they don't care man they're
carpet bombing channels yes
and so people are like tim why do you
keep saying talk to your doctor so much
first and foremost
i genuinely believe a private doctor
knows more
than than rogan fauci or anybody on tv
but also it's like
when we do when we do segments for this
show
we do a two-hour podcast of course in
the context of the live show
i'll say something like it is my genuine
opinion that
you know your medical history to a
private doctor like your personal doctor
he's going to know what's better for you
than anybody on tv or whatever
but then when we do another segment
because we break them up
that context has to be as well otherwise
we'll get banned i'm not exaggerating
people like
so if we if we talk for 10 minutes and
at the beginning of it i say make sure
you go to your doctor
we make a clip where we're like here's
what dr chris martinson was saying
and it has to be included youtube
specifically told me that
and then if we make another 10 50
minutes a second we're talking about
something else
and as soon as it comes up i have to say
it otherwise we get banned
okay well it's good information too it's
not just hyperbole it's not just it's
not just a show of faith i mean you
really do want to talk to your personal
doctor
about your personal medical business i
know it is
this is what candace owens was saying
was like why are people so dumb that
they're gonna like listen to a comedian
and then take that as medical advice
people need to have some responsibility
for their actions
that's a really good point like the the
media gets mad at joe rogan for having
an opinion on vaccines and it's like
yeah we do it it says a lot
about our society that
maybe it is more about youtube and their
faith and humanity
versus humanity in general like if
someone did a a podcast where they said
i'm not going to make a hypothetical
because youtube mad at me but if they
did if they if someone said something
like you know ride your bicycle
backwards it's fun
and then a bunch of people just went and
did it and got hurt youtube genuinely
believes people will watch peeps and
like they genuinely believe people watch
youtube channels and then just
instantly be like i'm gonna do
everything they just did like without
thinking about it
they all jumped off a bridge well isn't
that true isn't that kind of the divide
so i trust the people who follow me to
be intelligent and take responsibility
and they do i trust them youtube has
this other sort of patrician attitude
which is
listen we know we can handle this
information
but we're worried about other people
right so it's this very sort of
looking down that they believe that all
these other people are going to do
really dumb stuff so remember
way back when there was this whole thing
and i cannot even if i can say the word
but but this woman gave this
this guy died from this fish tank
cleaner and they used it and used it and
used it and used it and then his buddies
wrote and said by the way
bruce was a really careful guy he was an
engineer he
never would have spooned stuff in and by
the way his wife was new and she was a
complete raging
you know [ __ ] and so they were a little
worried
that maybe something had happened
because you know guys tend to
if they're gonna off their partners they
do it violently and women choose poison
so it's very old story and so
there's a real story there that that
somebody could look at and the media
just ran with it over and over and over
again
that that's the danger this one case
that what happened
and much more complicated than it's been
presented yeah
if if trump says something it's got to
be wrong and bad
there's something funny happening
recently trump goes to the border right
and uh kamala harris won't go to the
border she won't deal with immigration
trump announces he's going to go there
and he did and he had a press conference
with greg abbott
and of course then kamal immediately is
like okay i'm going i'm going i'm going
apparently she went to the wrong place
like she went to somewhere that wasn't
relevant necessarily 100 miles away yeah
but
close i i yeah i noticed uh someone
someone noticed this on twitter they
said
i think it was politico put out trump's
having a very very bad day
and they mentioned like i think the cfo
from trump organization was indicted on
like not paying taxes on benefits which
is the weirdest thing
like yeah but like this is such a slap
on the wrist level offense usually
they're just like hey you owe us a
million dollars and they go okay here's
your million dollars have a nice day
actually indicted the guy for not paying
taxes on his benefits
and so anyway you see this email come
out saying trump is having a really bad
day
and it's like they're just lying in wait
to say if trump does
anything we need to shut down that
conversation
before it could happen so trump
supporters are watching right
it's a bit we have this reoccurring
conversation with leaders and followers
and who's what and the the danger of too
many leaders you know the
but what i'm interested to hear what you
think about like just the nature of
humanity that we sort of segment into
this
one leader and a bunch of followers and
society it's almost now that society
thinks that they've just like this is
how it's going to be there's a bunch of
people that are followers by nature
you can't change it it's human nature so
we have to protect against that you know
we've got these people at the top or
whatever that are
supposedly like trying to build a world
around that
concept and i what do you think about
that
well if listen i'd be all for i would
love to be able to relax into the idea
that you have a good competent leader
out there right but i don't i really
honestly think our leadership right now
is taking us in a direction
this horrifying every dimension i look
at this right so the federal reserve is
now printed
it has a balance sheet that's eight
trillion dollars
look at the price for cold rolled steel
look at the price i mean do we just have
inflation raging and all they can think
to do is their precious stock market
they're going to keep throwing money and
it's the dumbest thing ever
right and that's the leadership we have
on the economic side
but i got to tell you again still i look
at what's happening ecologically around
here in terms of species loss
particularly at the bottom of the food
chain one does not willingly lose the
bottom of the food chain we're losing
insects
because we're losing insects we're
losing the birds and you know it's going
to be one of those things where you
can't quite predict what's going to
happen people like oh you know you lose
a few honeybees we get some honeybees
but
eventually you lose one too many species
and then the next thing you know you
have this mysterious brown mold going
across your crops you don't know what's
happening because there's something too
complicated to understand
so we need our leadership is taking us
down the wrong direction but they have
one
unifying thing if you can make money at
it it's an okay thing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you